se protéger tout en protégeant les
autres avec ses blues les soignants de
l'ehpad léopold bellan à magnanville
pourront continuer à le faire
200 blues attendue par les équipes ça
fait partie des équipements de
protection dont on a particulièrement
manqué on a eu des bons qu'au début on
avait des surblouse jetables et puis on
atteindre très rapidement été en rupture
de stock parce que beaucoup en demandait
et c'est la raison pour laquelle on
avait opté pour cette solution
alternative qui est kazakh
vous avez vu nos soignants à la création
à collectif blues pour l'hôpital depuis
son lancement en avril le comité
yvelinois réalisé plus de 1000 blues les
bénévoles ont pu connaître les
établissements grâce à ses liens avec le
département dans les cartons qu'on a
livrée jia principalement lundi jetables
d'aménager l'idée c'est que
progressivement on a commencé une
nouvelle ligne pour capitaliser sur du
lavables pour travailler sur du long
terme et pour que ce soit un peu plus
éco responsable dans ce moment où il n'y
a particulièrement besoin de solidarité
et devoirs des bénévoles se fédérer en
collectif pour apporter une pierre
essentielle à cette solidarité s'est
effectivement aux formidables et donc il
faut que le département soit là un site
de 3 124 lits particulièrement touchée
dès la mi mars
près de 40 % des résidents ont contracté
la maladie
les pâtes déplore plusieurs décès les
équipes restent sur le qui vive avec
comme mot d'ordre la vigilance